i had a very well what i think to be a
very
important uh actionable
insight about the nature of fear
fear is the mind killer
they've all read that bumper sticker
before
but even though we know this we know
that fear is the mind killer
many of us i believe certainly i
do find ourselves in
in the throngs of fear and anxiety on a
regular basis the lived experience
of fear is something i am well
acquainted with even though i know that
fear is the mind
killer and today my dear friend
marwan brought up
my preoccupation with death which is
definitely
definitely one of my greatest
one of my greatest fears right i fear
annihilation i fear the end of all that
is me i am
deeply attached to jason silva right
and uh and what he said to me you know
i'm in my 30s right i'm a young healthy
guy
you don't have to really start worrying
about death until you grow older and so
what marwan said to me was he said you
know what jason your
your fear your true and real and present
fear of death actually makes death
feel nearer
and it was like my brain exploded
because
the irony of a person who fears death is
that we want everything except
death to feel near right we're running
away
from death because it terrifies us you
know the more the
the manic incongruity of mortal beings
would dream of immortality and so
when he says to me you know your fear of
death makes death feel nearer
struck me as an annihilating insight you
know because
you know no self survives a real
conversation this is
what this is what that uh that poet
meant when he said the self doesn't
survive a real conversation because i
was slayed by that insight my fear of
death
makes death feel nearer so that means
that
it is not death itself that causes me a
headache
it is simply the fear of it the dread
that it awakens in me and so
this gave me a great insight about fear
in general whether it's death that you
fear
or failure that you fear or madness
that you fear um it is the fear of it
that haunts your days and nights so
you know something else that terrifies
me is losing control right losing my
mind getting
carried away in my art or in my
creativity or in the manic geometries of
associational thinking and just
taking things too far you hear about
artists like this all the time you know
they
they take it too far they lose
themselves they were never the same
again you know like
whatever they they are their work
destroys them and so that's another fear
that i have right the fear of madness
but
what happens instead is that the fear
itself becomes
a kind of madness so it becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy for it is
madness that you fear but it is not
madness that you have
what you have instead is just the fear
of madness which ironically is itself a
kind of madness because you
are no longer in control right you fear
losing control but you've already lost
it the moment you've
become afraid of losing it for the fear
of losing control means you've lost
effectively all control
to the fear now you are possessed by
fear so of course you're not in control
you are in the thicket
of panic and anxiety you are in
its grips so it's it's it's a very
interesting it's almost like um
i mean there's paradox there and there's
elements of of the way that that that
that we have we we can think ourselves
into sort of self-fulfilling prophecies
so again
i fear death and the fear of death
ironically paradoxically makes death
feel
nearer and so it robs me of the full
vitality of life
i shrink away from life and i die before
i die
you know ernest becker calls it jonas
syndrome and the same fear of madness
well
what what afflicts me itself what
afflicts me instead
what haunts me instead what maddens me
instead is the fear of madness
itself that becomes the madness and for
your failure too
you know if you're if you're constantly
afraid to fail
you never act you never do and if you
never
do well then effectively you failed
right so so the fear of failure that
holds you back from trying becomes
then the self-fulfilling prophecy of you
failing because you never tried to do
anything so of course you never achieved
anything so it's
the there's a lot of actionable insights
here but the more important insight i
think
is simply the realization that that the
cave you fear holds the treasure you
seek the only way
to kill fear is to face fear
right so so fear will win unless you do
exactly that what you're most terrified
of doing
right that's why jamie wheel and others
talk about the necessity of slaying your
ego or slaying yourself
practicing your death practices these
things that that
shatter all your stories [ __ ] your story
as jamie wheel says and
and then something that persists
something that survives can then
be reconstructed a new phoenix can rise
from the ashes this is what people mean
by death practices and so
the cave that we fear does hold the
treasure we seek you know and so it's
it's
it's a it's a very important thing for
me you know i can feel my solar plexus
still
you know aching for reconciliation
because i've put myself really on the
line here right
and so what is the answer what is the
answer what is the answer the answer is
we need not be afraid of that which we
fear
the answer is we need not be afraid of
that which we fear
in fact that which we fear is that which
we must do
and it is only this way that we move
forward
and and that's an amen that's a stand-up
and applause moment
right that really you know encapsulates
uh
um what what all moments of
transcendence are about which is that
they are surprising and also inevitable
i never thought that it was that it was
exactly by doing
what you're afraid of that you slay what
you're afraid of and move forward so
that's a surprise
but it's also inevitable for in
retrospect it's like uh-huh
of course that's exactly what needed to
happen
of course it is facing your fear
that annihilates the fear that ends the
fear and that allows you to break
through
to the other side so
[Music]
thank you marwan for making me realize
this today and
thank you guys for listening and and i
hope you know i hope that this is
something that uh i think i can
um you know this is my yellow brick road
now
i must do that which i fear
and i think that will uh
be the step function that i need for the
next
stage of my life wow that feels good
that feels
clean and clear and in integrity
and for that i am grateful
yeah thanks for listening i hope that
there's some material here that you can
relate to and that can add value
to your life as well much love guys
cheers wow